[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
I believe this is a cc Samantha's
warm-up song
MLB Special Assistant to the
commissioner also uh Cy Young winner
six-time All-Star CC will be part of MLB
Network's MLB tonight Clubhouse telecast
tonight Cardinals raised at six Eastern
so Albert Pujols is in there uh special
guest David Wright David Price Vince
Coleman Melvin Upton and uh CC launched
the Clubhouse game production series on
MLB Network as a way for fans to watch a
bunch of former players gather together
and see him how much they break down a
game live CeCe joins us now
uh what do you think uh so far of being
an analyst how would you rate your uh
your analytical
game
uh it's pretty good it's unconventional
though you know um because it's you know
I'm not really you know sitting there
like breaking down the game analyzing
the game is more like sitting there just
watching the game like I would do on my
couch and hanging out with friends so
um I just wanted to bring a different
element to to Vans and uh a different
way that you watch the game I actually
got this idea from I watched the Super
Bowl with Tiki Barber one year and he
was just like the way he could explain
everything and you know formations and
what's gonna happen next
um it was super cool so having that
experience I wanted to try to bring that
experience to fans uh with baseball
can you be critical
yeah you can for sure
um absolutely I mean it's hard for me to
be critical because I know how hard the
game is
um so you know for me it's it's uh it's
more about you know trying to shed light
on the guys and having a lot of fun but
I mean absolutely yeah you can be
critical for sure I mean we we get into
a lot of different things um during the
during the broadcast of the games for
sure yeah the no-hitter another
no-hitter last night we're finding a
rise in Combined no-hitters uh you
almost had one I think with the the
Brewers uh you led the league in
complete games twice do pitchers want to
have complete games now
yeah I think so I think guys want to go
out and and uh you know pitch deep into
the games I think you know what you saw
last night from Rob Thompson letting uh
Michael Lorenzen go you know 120 pitches
uh with something special you know I
mean um you know some other
organizations probably would have took
him out after the seventh inning with
100 pitches but
um you know those things are super cool
and special for the fans you know who
for the organization and yeah I mean
guys want to you know if you feel strong
you feel good you want to finish what
you start
could you have been a full-time hitter
full-time pitcher like oh Connie at any
at any point in your career
were you good enough hitter where you
could have
done it in the Major League
no I don't think so I don't think
there's anybody that can kind of do what
ohtani's doing um I mean it's obvious I
mean there's no it hasn't been anybody
you know to do what he's doing I don't
think I think there will be other two
ways but I don't think they'll be at the
level that that this guy's at so
um absolutely not I don't think I could
I could have done what he's doing no no
chance would you rather I was a good
hitter though I was a good hitter DP
would you would you rather face him as a
hitter or face him as a pitcher oh I can
get them out as a I can get them out uh
as a pitcher for sure okay how would you
get him out
oh I think
no there you go uh oh sorry um how would
you get Otani out
uh I would I I I always felt like I
pitched good against lefties so it would
be two seamers in
um right at the hands right under the
hands and then my you know back door
slider in the slider
what's that sound uh what is that sound
when somebody hits a home run
oh it sounds like a shotgun
[Laughter]
you know it right away how often would
you not even turn around a lot I never
turned around like I can just hear it I
can see the reaction and you know I'm
just waiting for another ball so that's
why I never really cared about guys like
pipping home runs or any of that stuff
like I never paid attention like I after
the ball was hit I was just looking at
the Umpire give me another ball and
let's get back to it you didn't care if
they did a bat flip or any of that stuff
no I really don't man it's hard to hit
in the big leagues man it's really hard
to hit and it's really hard to hit a
home run so I mean you know I like to
see the celebration so uh yeah I had no
problem with you know if I get I
remember I gave up a bomb one time to uh
Carlos Gomez in in Milwaukee absolute
bomb I mean over the slide he did his
whole little thing and I went back in
after to watch it because I wanted to
first one where the ball landed and two
when he did so it's all good uh you have
uh three career home runs I believe
three career home runs yeah all right
you got him off of who
uh Homer Bailey uh chanho Park and uh a
young guy from Cincinnati I can't
remember his name wait you only hit
three
you should remember that picture from
Cincinnati I definitely I definitely
still remember his name
uh the best thing about the one in
Cincinnati was uh watching Ken Griffey
Jr Chase it hit it the dead center field
watching him Chase it and go over his
head was the coolest thing
um you know you start to get on the
mound and you're thinking about things I
don't know if you ever threw a pitch and
before it got to the plate you realize
that that's going to be a home run
oh yeah I mean uh I was telling this
story the other day about Miguel Cabrera
um you know uh he was for me he's the
best right-handed hitter him or Manny
Ramirez are the best right hand hitters
that I've ever faced probably the best
in our generation and there was pitches
that you know if I threw him his first
half bat if I threw him a two seamer
away I knew if I threw him a two seamer
way later in the game he was probably
gonna hit it out so it was a game uh
game four of the ALCS 2012. first at bat
I got him out popped him up with a
fastball in and I I wasn't even thinking
about it and got to a second at-bat and
went back in for the for that pitch and
when I when I threw the ball I can see
like I was like oh that's it like when I
was letting the ball go I was like oh
that's a good spot and as I can see him
clearing his hips like when the ball got
halfway and I was like oh yeah that ball
ain't coming back
what do you say as the that's the pitch
clock been effective for both batter and
hitter or batter in pitcher yeah I think
so I think I think it's been I think
it's been great League wide um just
looking at the time of the games
um looking at the little stuff that you
know guys
um you know clean up the little stuff
around the batter's box and the little
dead time that we had in the game I
think it's uh I think it's great
um you know I mean I felt like you know
I pitched you know pretty quick and was
in a good Tempo so I don't feel like it
would have bothered me at all but
um as a fan I enjoy watching the games
now and
um it's something that you can really
digest in two and a half two you know
two and a half hours 200 2 hours and 45
minutes so it's been great build me the
uh perfect picture
as far as what like like players or
fastball slider change up curve
best fastball you know I like I love
Gary Cole's fastball
okay I love this fastball he can throw
it at you know any any quadrant he can
throw it to
um so I really love his his fastball I
would take Devin Williams change up
um the Airbender we came from from
Milwaukee I want his change up
um I want Blake snails slider
um his slider is real sharp he gets big
Leaguers to swing at balls that that
don't even go halfway to the plate like
so his stuff has to be nasty so
um I would take show haste I mean uh
coach fastball uh Devin Williams change
up and I and I want Blake snail slider
and then you're going to throw in
Mariano's cutter
I don't think anybody can really
replicate that you know I mean like
that's I mean if I had Moe's cutter I
wouldn't I wouldn't need anything else
but did you ever ask him did you ever
say did you ever ask him to teach you
oh yeah that's how I uh extended my
career at the back end around
2013 I lost a lot of velocity
um I went into Camp I lost a bunch of
weight I came into camp at 265. couldn't
throw a ball over 83 miles an hour
um and had to get my weight back up and
when my weight got back up I can only I
only got back to like 88 or 90.
um and during that time Mo was still
pitching and Andy Pettit had just
retired so Moe taught me to grip on the
cutter and Andy taught me the the
um I guess like the the arm slot and
that's how I was able to you know pitch
five more years
I got you homering off uh Ella elizardo
Ramirez
see now how I'm supposed to remember
that dude
it's only three guys come on it's like
remembering everybody's name in the band
that you're with I mean come on
elizardo Ramirez and you hit a two-run
homer off of him two Red Hook okay
um hey it's great to talk to you have
fun with the broadcast there and how's
your golf game by the way man I was
playing pretty good until today I just
shot 47 on the front so we got to see
what I do on the back it I have been
playing well up until about a week ago
so it's so fleeting but I love golf this
is all I do I wake up every morning and
put on golf clothes I don't even put on
normal clothes I wake up and put on golf
clothes and come to the course
what are you doing with the commissioner
are you on the job right now as the
Special Assistant to the commissioner uh
yeah I think I feel like I'm always on
the job you know I feel like this is a
part part of being on the job
um you know helping him you know with
player relations
um the rule change stuff
um you know kind of just anything
um you know uh on field operations
um you know kind of anything that he
needs help with
um you know it's been a lot of fun to be
able to to work at MLB I think as
players you know when you're playing
um you're trained not to like you know
the the other side and you know getting
out of the game and understanding that
you know that is a place that we can
work and now seeing you know Albert
Pujols is there
um you know Raul labanya has Jimmy
Rollins Ryan Howard uh we have a good
group of players Jed Lowry Nick Swisher
um it's a good crew of players that can
help
um bridge the gap between you know the
current players and the in the league
office
great to talk to you again thank you
Cece
good to see you uh CC Sabathia the
Special Assistant to the commissioner